[Music]
haha New Line Cinema Sonya Blade Waits
despite having him in her crosshairs so
that the nameless baddie can fire off
enough rounds to kill several innocent
people before she takes him out why is a
henchman attempting to kill Sonya when
Shang Tsung once her at the tournament
also none of these partying dancers
gives any about the gunfire going on not
three feet from them the penis tower
there's no one else so are you saying
that there can be only one every fucking
person on this pier is welding something
right now
Shang Tsung supposedly brings Scorpion
and sub-zero down here to kick some ass
once again forgetting that he brought
these people here for an important
fighting tournament your sideshow freaks
- your fighters then why was Shang Tsung
the one that tricked Sonya and Johnny
Cage into being here that is expressly
forbidden before the tournament
so if shang tsung had successfully
broken the rules would he have just
forfeited the tournament seems like an
unwise game plan even if you're pure
evil come with you where isn't this the
time for walking and not teleporting and
I come back at you now at the turn of
the time when to the realm of Earth
the Empress demon sorcerer Shang Tsung
and it's warriors after winning ten
straight victories in Mortal Kombat who
made up that the essence of Mortal
Kombat is not about death but life I
don't know Raiden I played Mortal Kombat
a bunch back in the day and I don't
remember anyone in the game saying keep
him alive when his life meter went down
well you're in the demon realm now so
probably not I know he's a Hollywood
diva and all but damn he's still a guy
right why so many fucking bags look at
your copies
how does Liu Kang know that Sonya has a
compass underneath her watch
lawless yeah I guess so it's like the
guy brought kicking and punching to a
nice fight I don't need your help that
is literally the first time you've ever
said anything remotely close to that
does every room in this castle come with
a table full of food including
complimentary giant chickens why are
there three guys each fighting Johnny
Cage and Liu Kang but Sonia only gets
one guy well hell I can do that
Johnny puts a spear outside this guy's
right arm but then in the next shot it's
on the other side starfruit come back so
these guys have just been standing here
the whole time while Lou Johnny and
Sonya congratulated themselves and no
one hurt them Sonya cuts her black pants
into shorts shorts which is awesome
let's just admire that for a second the
only problem is that we should be
admiring it for the rest of the movie
because there's no way she could have
packed an extra pair of pants for this
trip that she didn't know what's
happening why are the first two fights
on the beach with shanks on there and
like over 100 spectators and then BAM
suddenly Johnny Cage is fighting
scorpion in an empty orchard what
happened where did everybody go
who told Johnny Cage to go fight
scorpion and Orchard and why is this a
dream I thought this was a tournament
the rules further state that I can warp
you into another dimension at any time
oh he's gonna shoot fire at me hmm bones
bones bones shield perfect okay my
fields on fire now I need a weapon hmm
bones bones ah spear perfect set picture
supposed to be something Johnny Cage
carries around all the time or did we
just find out scorpion was secretly a
huge fan of Johnny Cage movies seriously
who decides which fights have spectators
and which ones don't
and how is all that communicated to the
participants is there like a printed
schedule with ring assignments and to
win your next match your next match this
is Mortal Kombat use the elements which
brings life
what cadmium disappointment
not very wise yeah so tough words from
shang tsung here but now this fight is
over for some reason and Liu Kang starts
fighting sub-zero and katana shows up
unharmed using telekinesis to tell Liu
about the element that brings life
sub-zero starts slowly creating a nice
shield around him never mind that we saw
him totally I Sidhu din like a second
before the tournament began use the
element which brings life well now why
did you tell him to remember your words
if you were just gonna show up and say
them again with your brain so Raiden and
katana got together and said we need to
get Liu Kang to somehow use water in its
next match because when he throws that
water at sub-zero during the obvious ice
shield move it'll turn into a huge
icicle and kill him are these guys and
who did they beat to get this far in the
tournament how would you even make a
bracket for this tournament start with
no Goro at all there'd be a marquee
matchups in the very beginning and then
Goro is allowed to fight whoever he
wants betting and following this
tournament is more complicated than
following the BASEketball playoffs as
art at this point seriously not seen or
heard of this Goro guy that has been
destroying everyone in the past 20
matches and remember those days back
when you were young playing Mortal
Kombat and you always insisted on
playing as art this is a Hollywood movie
about Mortal Kombat a game known for its
finishing moves and the big bad Goro's
first finishing move is a shoulder bump
from Louis no no I take issue with that
Shang Tsung art clearly got in some
punches in one kick girl's life bar
should have taken at least a little bit
of a dent not much of one but hardly
flawless
apparently Shang Tsung no longer has to
stand over people to take their souls he
can do remote sole taking them earlier
the guy's soul went into Shang Tsung's
hand but now it goes into his right eye
what an arts death have made more impact
on the audience if he'd had more than
five seconds of pre fight screen time or
you know if you'd actually been a
character from the game only one thing
can defeat you well and also
supernatural being who is eight foot two
and has four huge arms can defeat you
challenging Goro Lee so you can just
choose to fight Goro how does anyone
keep track of who's supposed to fight
who the rules are quite clear the rules
are actually not very clear at all
Mortal Kombat we find it
Raiden states that Johnny's weakness is
to jump into any fight to prove himself
and now he's smiling when Johnny does
the very thing he said was his weakness
gorel brakes Jonny sunglasses but the
lenses remain intact
those were $500 sunglasses Goro's just
now acting surprised that Jonny's behind
him after Johnny says an entire sentence
Goro falls off the cliff with his back
facing Johnny but you can bet your ass
he found a way to twist around and grab
the cliff on his way down
how did Johnny even come up with this
plan how did he know to go here did he
just walk around one night and find this
cliff that he could kick Gore off just
in case he ever found himself in that
exact situation what this dead thing
just sits around and waits for smaller
creatures to be thrown into it so he can
become a living being again at this
point the stomping or the running should
have begun I would say Liu Kang should
be dead or paralyzed after crashing into
this three-foot brick wall but the
construction standards in Outworld are
notoriously lacs but because Johnny
doing right now is there some reason he
can't come in from outside and help Liu
Kang who can just hit forward forward
and high kick it's not hard after you
practice couldn't Lu Kang just batter
shang tsung senseless while he's trying
to call up dead souls from the
underworld shang tsung summons five dead
warriors so they can approach Liu Kang
one at a time
hey when we install these spikes on the
floor let's make sure that they're in a
pattern so that some of the floor is
still completely safe he's hunched over
kick him into the spikes solidus victory
does anyone in this movie know what the
word flawless means all the souls Shang
Tsung took in his life were apparently
good people waiting to go to heaven I've
come for your phone but they plan to do
against this told Paul WS Anderson
your soul is mine
[Music]
[Laughter]
you